Sur WhatsApp, est-ce que vous savez
comment verrouiller l'application avec
votre empreinte digitale pour que
personne ne puisse la consulter ?
Est-ce que vous savez comment modifier un
message lorsque vous avez envoyé le
mauvais émoticône ?
Et est-ce que vous savez comment cacher à
votre boss ou vos collègues votre photo de
profil ou encore votre statut ?
Je vais vous dévoiler toutes les astuces
à connaître sur WhatsApp et bien plus
encore !
Quand vous venez de prendre une superbe
photo sur votre smartphone et que vous
voulez l'envoyer à quelqu'un sur
WhatsApp, il y a une chose qui est très
frustrante,
c'est que ça vous envoie des photos qui
sont compressées.
Ça vient dégrader la qualité de vos
photos et les personnes qui reçoivent les
photos, vos plus beaux souvenirs,
reçoivent une photo avec une qualité qui
n'est pas bonne.
Justement, WhatsApp a changé ça.
Mais par contre, il faut que vous fassiez
une action si vous voulez envoyer vos
photos en haute définition.
Alors je vous montre.
Sur votre smartphone, vous allez dans une
conversation et vous venez ajouter une
photo.
Vous cliquez sur le petit appareil photo
et vous venez choisir une photo.
J'ai une photo de chien là...
qui est très belle.
Ce qui est super important de venir le
faire si vous voulez envoyer vos photos en
haute définition, dans la meilleure
qualité, vous cliquez juste en haut sur
HD.
Comme ça, il vous propose la qualité de
la photo.
Soit standard, soit qualité haute
définition.
C'est la qualité que vous avez ici dans
votre fichier.
Et vous n'avez plus qu'à cliquer et
envoyer votre photo.
Quand la personne en face reçoit la
photo, elle voit un petit icône marqué
HD.
Ça veut donc dire que la photo est en
haute définition.
Et ce qui est cool, c'est que grâce à
cette astuce, plus jamais aucun souvenir
ne sera dégradé à cause de WhatsApp.
Et ça c'est bien.
J'ai une autre astuce qui est tellement
importante.
Si vous partagez le même smartphone entre
plusieurs personnes, ou que des fois vous
prêtez votre smartphone à des amis.
Ou que votre conjoint connaît votre code
et peut rentrer dans votre smartphone.
Ou que vos parents connaissent également
votre code et peuvent rentrer dans votre
smartphone.
Et que vous ne voulez surtout pas qu'ils
aient accès à votre compte WhatsApp, eh
bien c'est possible aujourd'hui de venir
verrouiller WhatsApp, en plus du code de
votre smartphone.
Ainsi, vous n'aurez pas un code, vous
allez le déverrouiller grâce à la
biométrie sur iPhone avec Face ID, sur un
smartphone Android avec un capteur
d'empreintes digitales.
Vous allez voir, c'est juste
extraordinaire.
Il vous suffit d'aller dans la
confidentialité.
Vous descendez tout en bas et vous allez
sur "verrouillage par empreinte digitale".
Et vous venez surtout l'activer.
Il vous demande de confirmer votre
empreinte digitale.
Posez votre doigt et ça déverrouille.
Et là il vous le marque.
Quand vous avez fermé l'application,
est-ce que vous voulez qu'elle soit
verrouillée immédiatement, au bout d'une
minute, au bout de 30 minutes...
Le mieux, c'est quand même immédiatement.
Comme ça, vous êtes tranquille.
Et lorsque vous quittez WhatsApp et que
vous voulez y revenir, vous cliquez sur
WhatsApp.
Il vous demande de mettre votre empreinte
digitale.
Vous le posez, vous déverrouillez et vous
êtes tranquille.
Comme ça, plus aucune personne indiscrète
n'aura accès à vos messages les plus
privés.
Les statuts sont super importants sur
WhatsApp et permettent de faire beaucoup
de choses.
Vous pouvez partager une photo en statut,
vous pouvez partager un texte.
Mais quand vous venez écrire un statut,
vous n'avez pas forcément envie que tout
le monde le connaisse.
Si par exemple vous voulez cacher à votre
boss que vous êtes en repos au lieu
d'aller au travail, ou si vous voulez
cacher à quelqu'un votre statut parce que
vous allez la défoncer. Ouais.
Vous pouvez choisir de ne pas montrer
votre statut à tout le monde.
Je vous montre comment ça marche.
Vous allez dans statut.
Et lorsque vous cliquez tout en bas pour
rédiger un statut, et bien vous choisissez
qui ne le verra pas.
Vous cliquez tout en bas sur "statut
contact", vous choisissez "mes contacts
sauf", et vous cliquez dessus, vous voyez
la liste de vos contacts, et vous
choisissez le nom de la personne à
exclure.
Comme ça ces personnes ne verront
absolument pas vos statuts, vous êtes
tranquille.
Alors faites le tour complet pour être
sûr que si c'est un truc professionnel,
tous vos collègues ne voient pas, sans
quoi vous risqueriez d'avoir quand même
quelques problèmes.
Les statuts existent en texte mais
également en image.
Si vous voulez d'ailleurs vous réagir à
la photo de statut de quelqu'un parce que
vous la trouvez absolument ridicule ou
que vous voulez envoyer des
encouragements. Vous pouvez le faire.
Il vous suffit d'aller sur la photo et de
venir réagir.
Vous choisissez l'émoji que vous voulez
mettre et vous l'envoyez.
La personne en face sera notifiée et
verra ce que vous pensez de la photo de
statut.
C'est bien mais des fois ça peut venir
créer aussi quelques petites frictions.
Donc pensez quand même à ce que vous
allez envoyer parce que des fois
on peut avoir des surprises.
Si vous avez envoyé un message vocal ou
un message texte que vous voulez
absolument supprimer parce que vous
l'avez envoyé par erreur, je vais vous
donner une
astuce qui va, ici, vous sauver la vie.
Vous cliquez sur le message que vous avez
envoyé, vous avez la petite corbeille.
Et vous venez le supprimer.
Cliquez sur "supprimer pour tout le
monde".
C'est quand même beaucoup mieux...
Sauf que là, vous verrez un texte où il
est écrit « Vous avez supprimé ce message
» et votre interlocuteur verra que vous
avez supprimé un message.
Il faut absolument venir le supprimer
pour éviter d'avoir des problèmes.
Ce que vous faites, c'est que vous
cliquez sur « Vous avez supprimé ce
message », vous cliquez encore sur la
corbeille et la notification sera
supprimée. C'est quand même très bien.
J'ai une autre astuce qui est quand même
très pratique.
Si vous êtes sur plusieurs conversations
à la fois, que vous parlez avec une
personne à qui vous envoyez un vocal,
vous parlez en même temps à une autre
personne
à qui vous écrivez des messages, eh bien
il est totalement possible de venir
enregistrer un vocal, de mettre la pause
et de continuer la conversation avec
quelqu'un d'autre et de revenir après
enregistrer son message vocal.
Je vous montre comment faire...
Lorsque vous enregistrez votre message
vocal, vous parlez "bla bla bla"
et vous avez la notification d'une autre
personne qui vient de vous écrire.
Vous mettez la pause, vous allez sur
l'autre conversation, vous envoyez votre
message, vous le tapez tranquillement.
Ok tout va bien.
Et ensuite vous revenez sur le message
d'avant et alors là vous vous dites...
"mince j'ai oublié ce que j'étais en
train de dire".
Et bien vous pouvez mettre lecture,
réécouter le message et ensuite vous
relancez l'enregistrement et vous n'avez
plus qu'à continuer votre conversation.
Maintenant la personne en face qui
écoutera le message ne saura absolument
pas que vous avez coupé et que vous avez
peut-être discuté avec d'autres personnes
entre temps.
Comme ça vous pouvez enregistrer un
message en plusieurs fois très facilement.
Ça vous donne des fois le temps de la
réflexion.
C'est pratique, c'est bien, c'est malin
et ça c'est super bien.
Autre astuce super importante si vous ne
voulez pas que quelqu'un en particulier
voit votre photo de profil.
Si par exemple lorsque vous êtes en
vacances, vous ne voulez pas que vos
collègues vous voient avec un collier de
fleurs autour du cou, et bien c'est
totalement possible.
Vous allez dans vos paramètres, vous
allez dans confidentialité, vous
choisissez la photo de profil.
Qui peut voir ma photo de profil ?
Vous mettez "mes contacts sauf"...
Alors, comme tout à l'heure, pensez
vraiment à bien exclure toutes les
personnes sans quoi vous aurez des
problèmes.
Et à ce moment-là, la ou les personnes
qui ont été cochées n'auront plus accès à
votre photo de profil et ne vous verront
plus en thong, avec un collier à fleurs ou
encore avec un cocktail bizarre.
Je sais pas vous, mais moi il arrive des
fois qu'il y ait des personnes pénibles
qui vous ajoutent à des groupes.
Vous ne voulez pas être dans ce groupe,
mais on ne vous demande pas votre avis et
on vous ajoute.
Alors vous le quittez, on ajoute encore,
on crée un autre groupe.
Bref, c'est très pénible.
Il est aujourd'hui totalement possible
d'empêcher cette personne extrêmement
pénible de vous ajouter dans un groupe.
Je vous montre comment faire.
Vous venez dans vos paramètres et vous
allez dans "confidentialité".
Vous descendez, vous cherchez "groupe" et
vous cliquez dessus.
Et là, "qui peut m'ajouter à des groupes
?
" Par défaut, c'est tout le monde.
Alors, vous pouvez aller soit sur vos
contacts, soit "mes contacts sauf", "mes
contacts sauf" c'est bien, parce que vous
choisissez le ou la personne pénible.
Vous cliquez sur son nom et cette
personne-là ne pourra plus du tout vous
ajouter automatiquement à un groupe.
Et lorsqu'elle essaiera de le faire, elle
recevra un message qui lui dira "ce n'est
pas possible, on ne peut pas, vous le
laissez tranquille" et elle pourra juste
vous envoyer une invitation à venir
rejoindre le groupe que bien évidemment
vous n'accepterez pas.
J'ai une autre astuce qui est juste super
maline.
Si vous utilisez comme moi l'application
WhatsApp Web, lorsque vous êtes sur votre
ordinateur, Mac, PC etc, peu importe, on
s'en fiche.
Et bien vous pouvez venir consulter vos
messages, répondre directement.
On retourne sur une autre fenêtre, on
gère ses mails, du traitement de texte, on
travaille, on se divertit, bref, on fait
ce qu'on veut et ça vous regarde.
Et bien il existe un moyen extrêmement
malin pour que vous puissiez voir les
messages qu'on vous envoie sans que la
personne en soit avertie.
Je vous montre comment faire.
Vous devez partager votre écran en deux.
Sur la partie de gauche ou de droite,
vous mettez WhatsApp Web.
Comme vous voulez.
Moi je l'ai mis sur la partie de gauche.
Et sur la partie de droite, vous mettez
une autre fenêtre, sur laquelle vous allez
travailler, vous divertir, regarder du
contenu.
Bref, ce que vous voulez.
Vous laissez la fenêtre de droite active.
La fenêtre de WhatsApp n'est pas active,
vous ne cliquez pas dessus.
Lorsque quelqu'un vous écrit, vous verrez
ces messages s'afficher.
Mais la personne qui vous envoie ces
messages, elle n'aura pas la notification
de lecture. Pourquoi ?
Parce que vous n'avez pas cliqué sur la
fenêtre à côté.
WhatsApp ne saura pas que vous avez pris
connaissance de ces messages.
Et donc la personne qui vous l'a envoyé,
non plus.
Vous pouvez choisir de cliquer dessus
pour l'avertir que vous l'avez vu ou pour
répondre tout simplement.
Mais si vous voulez faire comme si vous
n'aviez jamais vu ce message, et bien
c'est totalement possible.
Alors attention, vous pouvez le faire
avec une seule conversation en même temps.
Parce que si vous cliquez dessus pour
aller sur une autre conversation, la
personne sera avertie que vous avez vu
les messages, et là ce ne sera plus du
tout la même histoire.
Lors d'une discussion vidéo sur WhatsApp
avec des amis, vous voulez venir partager
votre lieu de vacances, montrer où vous
allez partir en vacances, sur la Côte
d'Azur, peu importe, à vous de choisir.
Vous pouvez venir aujourd'hui, et ce
n'était pas possible avant, donc c'est
quand même très bien, venir partager
l'écran de votre smartphone très
facilement. Je vous montre.
Lorsque vous êtes sur une conversation,
vous venez cliquez sur cette petite icône
smartphone avec une flèche.
Ça sera le partage de l'écran.
Vous pouvez commencer le partage ou la
diffusion de l'écran directement depuis
votre smartphone.
Alors bon, si ce n'est pas très pratique,
je vous montre un sens qui est un peu
étrange, un peu à l'envers.
Vous pouvez venir partager ce que vous
voulez, que ce soit une fenêtre,
navigation, des vacances, bref.
Vous pouvez partager aujourd'hui votre
écran très facilement.
Et une fois de plus, ça c'est super cool.
Allez une dernière astuce qui est l'une
des plus importante, si vous avez envoyé
le mauvais émoticône à quelqu'un, que
vous vous êtes trompé dans ce que vous
avez
écrit sur votre message et que ça peut
prêter à confusion et vraiment vous créer
des problèmes, et bien il est aujourd'hui
possible et avant on ne pouvait pas, c'est
très bizarre d'ailleurs, vous pouvez
venir aujourd'hui modifier vos messages
que vous
avez tapé directement sur WhatsApp.
Pour ce faire, vous allez sur votre
message, vous cliquez bien évidemment sur
votre message, vous allez sur les trois
petits points en haut et vous sélectionnez
"modifier".
Alors comme ça, l'émoticône qu'on a
envoyé qui n'est pas la bonne, eh bien
hop, on l'enlève.
On va envoyer par exemple, eh bien, je ne
sais pas moi, un petit sourire.
Tac, c'est parti, c'est modifié.
Alors pour autant, il sera écrit sur le
message directement "modifié"
mais ce n'est pas très grave parce que ça
pourra réellement venir vous sauver la
vie.
Alors attention vous avez juste 15
minutes pour venir modifier votre message.
Après 15 minutes ce ne sera plus possible
et là par contre vous serez réellement
dans une situation délicate
réellement.
J'espère que tout ce que je vous ai
montré là pourra vraiment venir vous
sauver la vie, vous aider et vous éviter
d'avoir des problèmes lorsque vous
utilisez WhatsApp.
Ce qui est cool c'est que WhatsApp vient
régulièrement ajouter plein de nouvelles
fonctionnalités pour que l'application
soit toujours plus simple, plus cool, plus
claire à venir utiliser.
Moi j'adore les applications comme
WhatsApp qui vont avoir de plus en plus
d'intelligence artificielle et d'ailleurs
si l'IA vous intéresse, j'en ai fait une
vidéo où je vous présente 9 IA absolument
incroyables qui vont elles aussi
complètement changer votre vie.
Allez voir la vidéo, vous serez pas
déçus.